what's happening reject nation gonna do
a Cobra Kai episode for you guys I'm
John he's Greg we are going to do
episode 9 different but same guys last
time had a pretty bitchin cliffhanger
can't wait to see what happens with
Johnny and Danny this time only a couple
episodes left John are you excited I am
to excel are you excited YouTube we can
only do a 10-minute cut of this the
reaction for you guys that's not our
fault letting you know it's just the way
the world works and most of our TV show
reactions get blocked and that's why I'm
patron we do full-length TV show
reaction watch alongs over there we do
weekly q and a's music video coverage
and that as well over there I personally
cover on my own attack on Titan and
almost done with season wanted season
for the flash been doing Gotham John
covers Riverdale did Atlanta currently
on Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
startup channel zero recently he also
does Steven universe in Adventure Time
some fun Saturday morning cartoons
together we'd cover
mahira academia Cobra Kai of course we
gotta finish Jessica Jones season 2 and
Black Lightning one of these days a
marathon anyhow before we go to Mexico
what we're going to Mexico
yeah you'll find out alright let's do
this
[Music]
really him
[Music]
the only way you can achieve it hey
that's what it loves breakfast some like
Tarantino [ __ ] they're gonna stay in
there like they're gonna talk this
Beatrix kiddo
the cave locks couldn't talk we got to
talk it out just a practice test
I can't strike first what would you do
meet them sometime meet you mom hey
daddy
that white kid who was there Victor I
just took my girlfriend there no clear
leader
[Music]
dude Miguel is your first girlfriend and
she's hot don't [ __ ] this up
they both [ __ ] up man they have a
special Miguel so every walk you
spray-painted a dick face you try to get
me banned from the all-valley
wouldn't it needed to be fixed with your
daughter her friends had a risky alright
he's probably half in the bag and
wrapped around to life in the bags a
good fast friend don't brag just give
him a car and get him out of your life
forever going on whoa dude and I don't
like he's becoming a Cobra time
not if we strike first ha they're gonna
meet up at the ending a Mexican kid
named one rule we found driving sorry
she's not gonna cut it
we're gonna do ice from YouTube I Johnny
Lawrence the new car food
he's the rusty of this house yeah relax
Danielle Danielle they like the same
song
[Music]
but the same babycakes oh they're gonna
be you said it at our music perfect
place to fight he's remembering memories
from the first movie I can't
[Laughter]
[Music]
one one day goes at the party all the
characters are gonna be unlike Bob is
gonna start fighting each other really
really make them so humid they were the
worst choice my friend Jean right there
haha but eight bombs that lucky eight
bottles of that vodka eight how much
money just mock it he's living I go to
wall up looks cool he's a friend who's
gonna tattoo someone's face big Hawk
lives a very interesting life we're not
getting to get all those money crazy
confrontation just love when things get
that close help her out
prison you say least gave me more
attention than I ever got it home oh
[Laughter]
[ __ ] she likes hog oh tell Jay he's
gonna get drunk a cheat on her or
develop a drinking problem no Robbie is
gonna somehow take her to that party
going to show up together there's so
many ways with this to get where it's
one of those to know which angle is Phi
you guys are something that is a doctor
now I'm seeing on Facebook it's a
Facebook really come on
what's a Facebook let's see what this
loser looks like let's go write a bunch
of insults on his page damn they were so
much happier in the past we use Miguel
stay faithful boys new complete 180 for
this guy so happy for Hawk do it man
[ __ ] gather with mr. Pitt for real
usually - just you're just a fugly [ __ ]
and your friends are all puncher turn
the [ __ ] face down oh don't don't you
do that this is way worse than him
cheating and he's got that monster movie
light
Oh oh wow
[Music]
oh what a mess it's weird to watch a
show where you can see everything that's
the critical point between expectations
and Robbie's gonna find a way he's gonna
find at the end at the party things like
okay he's a Noguchi or or they're going
together
oh man it's like weird to watch
something that is technically
predictable but is so emotionally
investing because it hasn't been like
intense in the first half of this show
at all yeah and the last few episodes
have introduced this like level of
intensity that you just don't expect to
dump because of the emotional stakes
that are at hand as intense as that was
if I have one criticism I mean you need
it to set up for like the tournament
scene at the end and for the conflicts
and stuff is when Miguel and Robbie have
a fight
he accidentally hits Sam and then you
know she storms off and Miguel is just
stunted like that's human but I hate
things when I'm like they just had a
conversation they could have solved this
you know yeah and and movies and TVs
they the TVs don't ever go for that but
in real life I feel like people usually
even have a young age they'll run up
they'll start a talk there's always a
conversation that they try to actually
have drunk whatever they try and in
movies and shows they never do I
definitely agree with you I don't like
that trope however in this episode I
didn't think it was handled in such a
way where I'm like well obviously they
could have just done it like you know
he's drunk off his ass made up his mind
dismayed by the image he sees literally
it's a brief exchange where he's not
really in a good frame of mind to have
just a calm conversation I mean I'm not
even a calm conversation but at least
like lash out or say like I saw you at
the house with him like I'll have that
eruption yeah got in trouble for
governing the house it blows up but I
feel like in real life that happens and
in the moment of the show I wasn't
bothered by it like in the moment of
watching it but looking back I'm like
that whole like lack of talking trope
really can get under my skin when I look
back on things even if it was an
argument a blow out more would have been
understood you know yeah like in real
life I think beyond that then it's still
perfect what happened I thought the way
the whole Robbie thing happened was
really real to me yeah that was natural
Robbie
trying to be like dad don't he's trying
to talk to Danny he's trying to tell him
I'm sorry no no no this this but you
know Danny's drunk and Danny won't have
it and Danny's feelings are hurt because
he found something special with Robbie
it brings back the whole I don't trust
the Lawrence thing well and he's just
spent the day bonding on Natalie with
with Johnny and and to have this you
know reversal has to be so jarring for
for him as a character yeah that was
real yeah that was real because Robbie
is trying to talk Danny won't have it
and he's pushing him out of his home and
he's he's really hurt and angry
Johnny storming off Johnny storm but
everywhere that's very real to me and
effective in that but that was
heartbreaking but that moment was real
nice too so he he just says some real
quiet and walks away you know and he's
now Robbie looks like the bad guy yeah
which is which it was an interesting
reversal in between the both of them
yeah yeah like he's the fulcrum of this
conflict now at least in this trio
Johnny and Danny were getting along and
of course Johnny lashed out at Danny you
know I'm sure Danny's not mad at Johnny
at all about what happened I'm sure
johnny is resentful of what of what the
situation is I can understand if we
check in on the next episode and Johnny
is mad at Danny for training Robbie
everyone with the ease
maybe yeah I can understand if Johnny is
upset but I could also understand if
most of the anger is directed at Robby
instead and then of course that was the
ultimate rivalry what's gonna happen at
the next episode with this tournament is
Robby gonna enter in himself under aha
you know the a jido years something like
that you know like what a complete
repeat like a of Johnny Lawrence's
protege and Danny loses a head-to-head
yeah is that I feel like something like
that might actually occur I've had them
I don't even know if Danny's gonna have
Robby do it or Robby's just gonna do it
on his own you know
some way yeah that's because I guess you
don't get as great of a sense for the
progress Robby has made like you know
Miguel they bother to have him like kick
asses and you have like where's Robbie
you mostly see him bonding with Danny
you see him fight those two dudes you
like try to break into the Larusso
dealership but most of the training and
stuff has been you know like a couple
moments of the house in that big moment
in the woods and well yeah but I can
definitely see them kind of sneaking in
that you know surprise for the Peppa so
because that would also tie things in
really crisply to have I don't know if
it would make that much sense for the
show to end with Miguel fighting just a
Rando it's just yeah you know I really
hope Miguel and Sam make up though I
mean it let's let me play that back for
a second of what happened when he hit
her yes he threw it looks like he threw
a punch and then hit her with the other
inside of his elbow that's not her like
a [ __ ] like Miguel throws a mean
inner elbow oh that's what happened it
looked like he tried like swinging and
he hit her so he doesn't punch her in
the face okay yeah I mean I think it's
pretty clear that it's it's like
collateral damage but still it's like
dude you're a mess if this is a bad
situation yeah so yeah that was bad I
hope
they can make amends though I mean young
love is very hard and confusing I really
hope she doesn't not dad plot if that
happens Robby and Sam get together that
would actually upset me yeah I would be
doing I'd be very annoyed by that
plotline and I don't think it would make
as much sense ultimately yeah you know
it would be it would be yeah just a bit
too convenient and a little too
unsatisfying what I did really like
though that I loved about this episode
was when it's slowed down and it looks
like they're gonna fight and then the
episode was dedicated the Johnny and
Dany storyline of them bonding that's
like a you know [ __ ] at the end but
there's the room and the key like
especially for like the season two you
gotta have that room for them to get
along they at least understand each
other better now
yeah regardless of what happens from
here on out they understand each other
yeah I don't think that it's impossible
for either of them to come around from
these situations with the stuff that
they learned and maybe you know reach
some kind of at least shakey yes you
know totally a ceasefire on this rivalry
you know is like the bare minimum of a
resolve I guess and also too I mean the
whole plot line with you know the other
Cobra Kai students like crashing the
birthday party and stuff like that I was
not expecting a fight by atomic front
wedgie
hey man hashtag I guess what makes is so
intense is how they built it in such a
way where you just don't see intensity
coming in this show yeah it's more like
the first half of those experiences but
this is really enjoyable this is really
fun this feels like real people and it's
really funny now we're entering into
plot territory really fun game so so
long you really really really did such a
good job at building your emotional
investment into these characters I yeah
well yeah and I think the way they drew
the first half of the season really
makes a lot of these contrasts work
because at the end of the last episode
like you just wouldn't expect something
like that to happen yeah come and torch
his car yeah and yeah that kicks I get
what y'all were saying things
to kick it seems like into a different
gear and his last handful of episodes
and I am so excited I love this
alright well you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation keep a look out for
our episode to the finale check us on
patreon full line TV show reactions
weekly Q&A is a music video coverage
love to have you become a patron jet
today